hola
[Música]
repudio e indignación por la muerte de
una salvadoreña a manos de cuatro
policías mexicanos en tulum el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
condenó enérgicamente el asesinato y
afirmó que victoria salazar arriaga de
36 años había sido objeto de un trato
brutal el hecho generó protestas en
mexico mientras en el salvador piden
justicia
avanzan venida police el juicio contra
el ex policía derecho ven acusado de
asesinar por asfixia al afroamericano
george cohen el abogado de la familia de
florete consideró que el juicio es un
referéndum sobre la libertad y la
justicia de eeuu durante la primera
jornada a cerca de 200 manifestantes
pidieron justicia
tres de los principales grupos étnicos
armados de mianmar lanzaron un ultimátum
a la punta militar del país para que
frenen las matanzas indiscriminadas de
manifestantes la advertencia de estos
grupos guerrilleros se produce tras el
fin de semana más sangriento hasta el
momento ya ha elevado la cifra de
muertos a 510
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 cerro blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en mexico donde la muerte de la
salvadoreña victoria salazar a manos de
cuatro policías en la ciudad de tulum ha
generado el repudio de toda la sociedad
asociaciones de feministas y de
migrantes condenaron la muerte de
victoria que fue sometida durante un
operativo policial el presidente de
méxico condenó la violencia machista que
en su país mata a 10 mujeres al día
mientras tanto el presidente del
salvador dijo estar seguro que el
gobierno mexicano aplicará todo el peso
de la ley
una escena que ha causado conmoción en
el salvador y en méjico
pero también la muerte de la salvadoreña
victoria salazar a manos de cuatro
policías en la ciudad de tulum pesó en
la inauguración del foro generación
igualdad la conferencia internacional
que se celebra en la ciudad de mexico
busca determinar acciones concretas para
avanzar hacia los objetivos en materia
de igualdad fijados por la onu para el
2030 sin embargo durante la ceremonia de
apertura la atención recayó en la
condena del homicidio de victoria
salazar la mujer salvadoreña muerta a
manos de la policía mexicana el pasado
sábado a causa de una fractura en la
columna durante su violenta detención
desde el día mismo del asesinato el
mandatario salvadoreño nadie buque le
pidió justicia estoy seguro que el
gobierno mexicano aplicará todo el peso
de la ley a los responsables mi pésame
para la familia de victoria sobre todo a
sus dos hijas
el presidente mexicano aseguró que no
habrá impunidad para los policías
implicados en la muerte de salazar que
serán procesados por feminicidio
castigado a los responsables de este
crimen
brutal
el vergonzoso
y doloroso sensible
por otro lado el presidente francés y el
secretario general de naciones unidas
pronunciaron discursos más amplios de
denuncia a la brecha y a la violencia de
género acentuada por la pandemia
kobe 19 también nos ha recordado la
persistencia de la violencia que sufren
las mujeres esta pandemia en la sombra
que se alimenta de las situaciones de
confinamiento en el exterior del palacio
nacional la protesta de un grupo de
mujeres recordaba que la cercanía de la
muerte de salazar con la celebración del
foro no es una coincidencia temporal en
méjico diez mujeres son asesinadas cada
día
y precisamente ante la violencia
policial policial ayer lunes comenzó uno
de los juicios más seguidos de las
últimas décadas el del derecho bien el
ex policía acusado por el asesinato de
george flight en mayo 2020 el juicio se
centró en esclarecer la causa del
fallecimiento del afroamericano para lo
que la parte acusadora utilizó el vídeo
de la muerte de floyd como prueba
principal con este material audiovisual
en el que se ve como floyd no puede
respirar contestó al argumento del
abogado de la defensa que aseguró que la
víctima abuso de medicamentos debido a
una dolencia cardíaca el informe se alba
santana
diez meses después del caso que reabrió
la herida racial en estados unidos la
muerte del afroamericano church floyd el
ex policía acusado por su asesinato
directo a bing se sentó en el banquillo
de los acusados el juicio se centra en
esclarecer la causa de la muerte de
floyd la acusación usó el vídeo del
fallecimiento de la víctima más de nueve
minutos en los que se puede ver al ex
policía con la rodilla en el cuello de
floyd mientras él clamaba que no podía
respirar
un rato más mantener sus cualidades
ajenas cuando esto pues guay
ustedes aprenderán que en los últimos
nueve minutos y 29 segundos de vida del
señor floyd en ese periodo de tiempo se
puede ver como su muerte encaja con la
de alguien que muere por falta de
oxígeno podemos señalar la evidencia en
el vídeo lo podrán ver ustedes mismos
también verán evidencias de lo que no
fue no fue por ejemplo un paro cardíaco
fatal no fue por ejemplo un ataque al
corazón pero guard
así contestó la acusación al abogado de
la defensa que sostuvo que floyd tuvo un
paro cardíaco provocado por el abuso de
medicamentos y una dolencia cardíaca y
pidió aplicar el sentido común en el
juicio de chauvín
howes el sentido común nos dice que
siempre hay dos lados en una historia y
el sentido común nos dice que tenemos
que examinar la totalidad de las
circunstancias que determinan el
significado de las pruebas y cómo se
pueden aplicar a las cuestiones de la
razonabilidad de las acciones y
reacciones
pero algunos de los primeros testigos
que empezaron a dar testimonio también
constataron el uso excesivo de fuerza
por parte de la ex policía
y cuanto más tiempo pasaba con la
rodilla en el cuello más se podía ver
como floyd se iba desvaneciendo fairway
la muerte de floyd desencadenó las
mayores protestas por la igualdad racial
de eeuu en las últimas décadas y la
sentencia del caso marcará un antes y un
después para la comunidad afro
una nueva caravana de migrantes de
honduras muchos de ellos menores de edad
comenzó a formarse ayer lunes 29 de
marzo en el norte de ese país desde
donde esperan partir mañana miércoles 31
de marzo con rumbo hacia eeuu la
convocatoria de una nueva caravana ha
sido difundida como en otras ocasiones
en redes sociales pero hasta ahora no se
conoce quién es o quién es el
responsable de esta organización esta
nueva movilización podría cruzar por
corintio o agua caliente ambos puntos
fronterizos con guatemala
el presidente de brasilia y
revolucionario reemplazó a seis de sus
ministros el cambio gubernamental más
grande desde que alcanzó la presidencia
visionario se enfrenta a la presión
derivada del creciente descontento por
las muertes por coronavirus y el retorno
a la política del ex presidente luiz
inácio lula da silva
bolsonaro ha sacudido la base de su
gobierno y ha realizado de una vez seis
cambios en el gabinete que han sido
anunciados a través de una serie de
tuits tres ministros han dejado el
gobierno incluido el ministro de
exteriores- ernesto araújo y el ministro
de defensa fernando acevedo de silva
araujo se alineó con la anterior
administración estadounidense y se
pronunció en contra de china el
principal socio comercial de brasil esto
le granjeó las críticas del presidente
que consideró que su postura en pidió un
acceso más rápido a las vacunas contra
el coronavirus por otro lado la salida
de acevedo del ministerio de defensa fue
una sorpresa ha sido reemplazado por el
actual jefe de gabinete de bolsonaro
walter souza braga neto uno de los
muchos ex generales del ejército en la
cúspide del gobierno este año los
índices de aprobación de bolsonaro han
descendido la pandemia ha matado a más
de 300.000 personas en el país que ahora
se encuentra en su peor momento con más
de 3000 muertes diarias
bolsonaro ha mostrado dudas sobre las
vacunas y se ha opuesto a los
confinamientos respecto
y obviamente necesitamos respetar a los
ancianos los enfermos y aquellos con
problemas médicos
pero qué pasa a la compra sin si paramos
todo si nos paramos a mediados de marzo
bolsonaro ya había realizado un cambio
de gobierno
reemplazando al ministro de salud
eduardo para suelo el cuarto en la
cartera de este gobierno quien había
sido ampliamente criticado por la
lentitud en el programa de vacunación el
derramamiento de sangre y la brutal
represión del ejército de mianmar contra
los manifestantes antigolpistas ha
llevado a tres de los principales grupos
étnicos armados del país a lanzar un
ultimátum a la junta golpista y amenazan
con anular su acuerdo de alto el fuego
si continúa la violencia indiscriminada
contra los manifestantes con más de 500
muertos desde el golpe de estado militar
del pasado primero de febrero
tres dedos al aire la insignia de las
protestas como despedida final continúan
los funerales por los más de 100
asesinados durante las manifestaciones
prodemocráticas del fin de semana en
mianmar la jornada más violenta desde
que comenzó la represión de la junta
militar
mi querido hijo nos dejas como deseabas
las fuerzas de seguridad no serán
perdonadas hasta el final rezo para que
nuestro pueblo de mi alma logre la
victoria que tú deseabas tu deseo se
cumplirá
y la brutalidad del calmado ejército
birmano desde el golpe de estado del 1
de febrero ha matado a más de 500
personas y unas 2500 están detenidas una
deriva violenta que no parece amainar a
pesar de las múltiples condenas
internacionales los birmanos iban
saliendo a las calles de todo el país en
medio de un clima de terror una
situación que ha llevado a los grupos
étnicos armados como el ejército de
arakan y sus dos grupos asociados en la
alianza de la hermandad a unir sus
fuerzas amenazando con reanudar su lucha
contra los militares y no cesan las
matanzas de civiles un nuevo giro que
podría degenerar en una guerra civil el
portavoz del ejército de arakan acá en
tu casa dijo a the irrawaddy que es hora
de que las organizaciones étnicas se
unan para proteger a los civiles
oprimidos del régimen militar debemos
hacer nuestro mejor esfuerzo para
proteger las vidas y propiedades de las
personas oprimidas dijo los recientes
ataques aéreos durante el fin de semana
sobre la minoría étnica karen la más
antigua del país y los enfrentamientos
entre el taimado y la guerrilla de la
unión nacional karen que acordó una alta
el fuego con el gobierno en 2012 han
provocado un éxodo masivo hacia
tailandia
a más de 3000 hermanos se están
intentando cruzar la porosa frontera en
francia a medida que los ingresos en
unidades de cuidados intensivos de la
región de el de france continúan
aumentando sin pausa los expertos
advierten que los médicos podrían pronto
tener que empezar a escoger a qué
paciente salvar con los contagios al
alza y los hospitales quedándose sin
camas de terapia intensiva los
profesionales de la salud siguen
ejerciendo más presión para que se
implemente un confinamiento nacional
a los hospitales de la región del gran
parís están al borde del colapso así lo
dicen médicos de hospitales que
advierten de que las unidades de
cuidados intensivos pronto estarán
desbordadas en la región de ildefons y
que en las próximas dos semanas el
personal tendrá que empezar a escoger
pacientes en un diario del domingo 41
especialistas advirtieron que los
doctores tendrán que empezar a escoger a
los pacientes para poder salvar la mayor
cantidad de vidas posible dijeron que
esto afectaría a todos los pacientes
aquellos que contrajeran kobe 19 y
aquellos hospitalizados por otras causas
uno de los que firmaron esta carta dijo
que los doctores se verán en una
situación imposible y llegamos al punto
en el que más de 50% de los que son
admitidos tienen menos de 50 años y
estamos cerca de que eso pase será
extremadamente difícil elegir a quien
salvar entre los menores de 50 las
unidades de cuidado intensivo están
tratando a una media de 1.400 pacientes
al día durante este mes una cifra menor
a la registrada durante el repunte de la
prima
hola en la primavera pasada y eso pasó
bajo un confinamiento mucho más estricto
con el 80% de los procedimientos
quirúrgicos pospuestos si si no hay más
restricciones para el 22 de abril
tendremos un 30% más de pacientes en
cuidados intensivos en comparación con
la primera ola para todo aunque
california van los médicos advierten de
que las medidas de confinamiento
aplicadas en parís y otras regiones no
serán suficientes para frenar los
contagios y que los hospitales pueden
tener que empezar a rechazar pacientes
china dio el último paso para imponer en
hong kong un sistema electoral que les
permita aumentar su control sobre el
territorio y complicar el acceso a la
oposición prodemocrática al parlamento
de la ciudad desde beijing nuestro
corresponsal de adrián foncillas con
todos los detalles
el sistema electoral de hong kong aunque
alejado de los estándares occidentales
era bastante más democrático que el que
habían dejado los británicos y permitía
la disensión política eso va a ser
bastante más complicado a partir de
ahora al parlamento pasa de 70 a 90
asientos y solo 20 serán de elección
directa además el comité electoral podrá
medir el patriotismo de los candidatos y
rechazar a los que juzgue tibios
pekín considera la reforma como
indispensable porque el bando opositor
antes de las elecciones del pasado año
que fueron finalmente suspendidas por el
coronavirus había anunciado que votaría
en contra de todas las acciones de
gobierno para forzar su bloqueo así que
pekín ha querido eliminar ese riesgo de
todas formas las próximas elecciones
parecen ahora una inquietud menor para
los políticos opositores una cincuentena
de ellos se enfrentan a largas penas de
prisión después de haber sido detenidos
en aplicación de la nueva ley de
seguridad nacional aprobada el año
pasado tanto esa ley como la reforma
electoral son la respuesta excepcional
de pekín a unos problemas también
excepcionales como fueron
las protestas violentas que durante un
año sumieron en el caos a hong kong
hasta aquí el informativo de france 24
contenido con nosotros semántica para
todos
[Música]